praticamente gabriele e gianluigi hanno
litigato
no adesso con questo nuovo blog
loro però non è che sono proprio le
persone più affidabili per dire a finale
che ti aspettiamo quello di cali
affidabili e successo che un giorno gli
ho detto avete fatto qualcosa
no non abbia ancora detto niente il
giorno dopo pure aveva quel giorno dopo
pure un certo punto non vendette colpa
sul colpo sono bravi dobbiamo fare ma
certo e quindi alla fine in realtà la
mia tecnica è stata dire che era colpa
che gli altri ci siamo trovati nel
frattempo con ragazzi per favore
possibile sono poi sembra che parlino
tranquillamente guardate come fai
allora ragazzi come siamo rimasti tra
cui due non avete parlato
no secondo me non è così se ti dico la
fascia capace
ho capito che una ragazza è l'unico che
chiede scusa sono io
le altre persone pensano di non
sbagliare nulla è vero lo so di aver
sbagliato detto scusa ma io non fare
che il progetto la mente io accetto
tutto poteva dire in barca perché grande
barca fatiche non sanno benissimo
ognuno fa il suo tu sei
deresponsabilizzato da trainare la gente
ma tu luigi a chiaro che cosa è fare
bene
ritengo che ci sia molto bravi nel far
emesso e devo dire che anche io ritengo
che nel suo ruolo ottimale ok quindi un
abbraccio riappacificazioni non ho
rancori non solo è un ciccione si è
trovato ammesso non ammette a mezza luna
faccio fatica a tenerlo no picchetti
sconocchia lo stiamo andando via palermo
per dimagrire ma manco per idea è più
grave come se ci avessi il panda addosso
ma manco bene ascolta non stiamo dando a
cui hanno per un periodo che dimagrisce
perché ha mangiato troppo o no no no no
stiamo portando il vescovo ne vado dove
preso non importa su minore ma è grasso
ma per pazienza ce lo teniamo grasso
basta che non è malato ma questa deve
fare ginnastica ma io devo prendere per
cosa perché grasso e deve venire da me
perché per dimagrire è certo e io lo
farò tutto cane quando tutti noi di fare
più nel cappello e cucinare emerge non è
mai pronta la storia è è pronta la
ciclovia ma non manderò lo sarà finchè
sono giunte insomma no no un mese vai a
fare eccetera eccetera scusa non ti
faccio una ciclo nonna ma scusa matteo
15 cosa che non faccio una ciclo dove
lui si sa mai avuto e mi compete ma non
mi far danni a tutto guarda che diventa
pure vede niente ha detto
in realtà se contento di averlo però il
fatto è che questo cane telequiz questo
sbaglia al mobile nonna non starlo ad
ascoltare lo stop ottenendo prigioni del
teatro rinasca volturino e che così
stiamo un possibile galizia e dura curdo
ma ce la puoi fare tu ci credi chi sta
male e poi te lo faccio molto fattami
nome fa parte scena nonna la prima
settimana sarà dura poi ti abituerai c'è
una cosa che vende ci chiama l'auto una
dieta sana
adesso ti abituerai siamo soli chiarito
questo stasera prima serata con gli
amici ha dimorato mezzo però resta
salpando giuste le sue palline e sta
distruggendo tutto
senza contare che prendato qua in cucina
è caduta per sbaglio questa calamità che
gli era stata regalata a ieri
ieri in questo è vero un figlio che si è
perso non so credo che sia aveva una
coroncina che si è staccato ora
attaccato con lo sputo non verrà mai più
incolto quel culto che stiamo vivendo
guarda un bullo sta aspettando te non ci
pensare quindi questa sera
la musica questa sera ok canton cina non
come letti dai ricordi paragonabile solo
al comune della pioggia e vento che
soffia tra le fronde degli alberi con
elsa che canta una dolce nenia bella a
tutti i ragazzi appena arrivato ad
amsterdam
un botto contento e la mia volta che
bello qui ho rischiato di fiamme laner
perché hanno fatto scenda puffo dal
treno per un problema tecnico presa st
coincidenza il ritardo ovviamente so
arrivato agli imbarchi che avevano
chiuso da dieci minuti la tizia o duda
prega in ginocchio per fame nervosa ma
prendevo dritto per cosa fare per
levarmi tutto questo stress di dosso no
una infinita lunga grossa interminabile
passeggiata nel centro diana buongiorno
territori farvi vedere la mia faccia
perché in questo momento è terribile non
sono riuscite a dormire tutta la sera
colpa sua si era posto un po di attività
fisica della ventesima che facciamo dvd
ma non ne stai facendo più sono finte in
questo modo cosa stai cercando di
esprimere dai facciamoci vedere seconde
figurini fermo per la finisci di
mangiare dobbiamo andare al magazzino a
fare delle cose son svegliato adesso è
vabbè finisci dai quanto ci metti guarda
che ha trovato nonna
un giochino di culto chissà guglielmo
che stanno andando male senza il suo
giochino poi
sbagliato pezzo inviamo la sera è
arrivato finalmente il momento di
mandarsi in pappa il cervello ragazzo
adesso mi vado a fare una bella visita
al museo di van gogh
eccoci qua li stiamo arrivando per
mostrami valenza che facevo a casa quasi
come l'originale resterà l'abbiamo detto
del nostro amico fidato grande classico
tutto a posto linz
non c'è ma dal tetto del magazzino
volevamo questa cosa l osso io sono il
tuo maestro e l'inizio della dieta
bisogna inizia a smaltire quasi non
avevamo la roba magazzino tanto in tanto
ci sarà tutta la matura biscotti
nascosti nei magazzini leila in questi
così sui veicoli elettrici a me tocca
andare a piedi
maledetti hanno lasciato solo
sentiva camminare per 33 per gli cammina
siamo in questo momento con la linea a
lavorare l'ho fatto riunioni incontri
adesso stiamo girando roba del canale 15
saranno video dove solamente questa
meravigliosa ragazza ci sarà come il
regista unica ragazza prima di dire
perché mi odia martorelli come ti odia
quello che gira poter sopportare che non
è solo lui l'aveva già privato gianluigi
con il doblò siamo pronti per lo scarico
di te amici ed entrate se ti serve
qualcosa non lo dobbiamo comprare porta
a bologna se c'è qualcosa di
interessante come troppo metà brano
monumenti è bello prendi green tutto
tutto un paio di sci fi e finalmente
abbiamo trovato il pollo ma ragazzi ma
questa atmosfera tipo film horror ma che
volete sentito anche molto rumore
interessa non ne ho idea
guardiamo tirare antiquariato a questo
articolo
questo è realmente non c'è nulla è mai
visto un bolognese che in giro a bologna
sappi ci crede già non ce la faccio più
ad aspettare ed a roma che faremo e non
vedo l'ora di fare questa cosa è
arrivato il momento di farsi 150 g di
hamburger da febbo
stiamo parlando di un distributore di
felicità ossi
ma questo è un sogno dietro c'è la
cucina e in continuazione rimpinguano
questi fornetti che tengono caldo i
panini i premi
ciao proprio sottrarre ben sette
comprensori sottoposto lo apro a roma
questa la finalità di slanina ma fatte
con la moglie la grillo e di nuove celle
urbana ma grillo ma scusate ma che per
l'itala qualche stretta poca lasciarlo
entro servire niente intanto sono primi
tempi stretti la carichiamo per cosa
ricorda che c'è magari te cioè divenuta
un pagliericcio divenne una topaia c'è
spazio però chiarendo ma non temo un
macchina non esiste domani dal prossimo
ottobre a roma oggi o mai più no ma
anche domani possiamo accettare come
risposta è parte integrante della
macchina e dell'equipaggio
partire la macchina tu lo sai come a
bologna aperti corone ai fatti tokamachi
una volta mi ascolta ascolta tu sei uomo
distinto guarda che ho mai scritto che
se c'hai 20 colori addosso senza
scherzare
immagino che tu torni a bologna gli
amici e ragazze le donne i genitori e
genetisti vedono con la macchina carica
di balocchi doni ma chi è mio figlio
contro voti ce li vogliono bene tutti
sei un grande e dimostra di essere un
grande spalla stato tutto oppure ce
n'eravamo quasi fatta pronto capri
salentina cosa nel magazzino c'era la
rete del letto quella tua quella da una
piazza e mezzo e serve solamente che in
direzione di farmela vengo a prendere
che altro c'era che mi può servire non
solo non c'erano cioè noi siamo sempre
non c'era quindi in cantina di
incatenarmi dici ok da un'altra casa
riguardo al magazzino io qua ho trovato
il quadro
quello che mamma diceva bellissimo con
il messia che benedice secondo me quello
ha un valore
lei era pieno oggi vabbè quindi
controlla se c'hai le aree di niente
mary carbone
vabbè ma anche talassi qui itinerante
venduto 20mila euro non puoi entrare
nella vasca con è questo quel titolo
spazio mio mulino di privacy ma anche
d'ora a chiudermi la porta perché sennò
entry zio che bellezza
io lo vorrei poter mangiare la pizza
tranquillo sul divano non puoi mangiare
questa pizza non ti farebbe bene proprio
alla salute di papà
la tappa è uno che ha perso tutto
io vado a mangiare la pappa al senato
tra cugine tutto bene
scusatemi ragazza che viene interdetto
arti sono prestato alla libertà di
aderire ad un evento di beneficenza ad
aiutare i bambini con rita verità è
questa la parte bella della notizia una
parte carina non brutto definiamola una
parte certo dai sei aree perché mi
lasciare ti preoccupare mente di un
pacco di carone
e partiamo quando ultima giornata con
dinho dovevo fare con lui dei giri per
questo week end sulla neve
facciamo un recap devo andare a prendere
da decathlon delle cose dei miei stivali
quelli da neve i guanti la tuta ce la
facciamo per star era già al un po i
tiri accompagno a casa che il tuo tempo
è finito so che sei triste e lo so ti
prego non fare così non fare così ti
prego e poi dovrò fare la valigia da
solo mi preparo per questa bella
esperienza
iniziamo e sconfiniamo più pur non
facendo giusto in questi grazie per la
compagnia lari lui e sport per una roma
che domani se parte sulla neve insomma
sempre che riesca a partire cioè il
treno in ritardo di un ora e trenta
quindi se intorno entro domani bella
regalo ma chi è che è stato bravissimo
ha riportato avete visto che cosa ha
detto borriello ma lo rimettiamo di
grasso subito sì soprattutto siamo qua
perché davvero non sciatore e gianluigi
pure mi per st
ora hanno una specie di alberi thing
questa qui è pazzesca questo one piece è
stupenda chiudevo in bollette quanti nel
senso di te un pezzo manga va bene
grazie cama non è tanto difficile sciare
spero che tu non ci iniziare alla tua
età è difficilissimo peschi di farsi
seriamente male ma seriamente tipo cioè
che cadono tipo inizia a salutare i suoi
fan sul web
vogliamo fare anche un attimo la prova
costume ma no allora innanzitutto se a
milano si mangia bene si fa la vera
piadina romagnola attenzione vera
betania roma in aria perché capire la
degli scenari ed è già nota per
l'occasione peroncino si scavo la
missione si siamo ragazzi si avverta
benissimo sono tornato a casa e non
potete capire quanto sia silenziosa cioè
stare senza il cane loro parte ti fa
dire lamone che bello se non ha perso
nemmeno un essere meno a cui badare
dall'altra parte della solitudine in
foto vado ad arcore store atto le
dormite come il cane fra sarah sarà la
brina faccia tolleranza zero lavori
stradali sulla neve devo fare la valigia
e si parte poi si parte rieccoci a r n
i legali dalla
arriva ragazzi
il prossimo episodio perché lo sto
facendo è un adrenalinico renali no
vedremo sapete che appena non ci
vedranno li ammazzano a me mi ammazzano